hello welcome to this video playing
eight miles high at color Stan uh-huh so
GM he probably made the GM title in the
meantime but never bothered to change it
here on the eyes you see yeah that's one
of those lines where I never looked at
this I mean I play the Banco but yeah
and I never looked at this stuff with e3
it's not a bad line at all yeah just
making up things here at one point of
Luke a three years said after eight eggs
be five what sometimes can can even take
with the pawn um so here but Tok won't
take with the pawn of course he will
take with the bishop how do i establish
counterplay I need the night somewhere
on the queenside I just wonder wonder
how exactly and where
k Queen 85 is never really doing all
that much as Bishop tutu is happening
okay you went back he wants to check on
b5 in one move it's clearly as I DM
Knight b6 it is not going anywhere as
the thing
yeah this is not a happy move this
always the problem with with the bank of
gambar if you just play it with some
basic knowledge then if someone plays
somewhat a well-thought-out line that he
knows well then you're almost invariably
getting into trouble because it is such
a the compensation is very fragile that
Saints in some cases and down here i'm
just a pawn down I'm just born down
yeah this is going nowhere it I don't
see what to do ok so maybe see 493 and I
mean I have to do something so I cannot
even take on bigger because that a three
workers covering this fantastic
preparing the rook to be am I mean the
night is at least somewhat irritating
find my hope yeah this is also an issue
not be five possibly coming up I queen
the two is also problem poor
might be five queen bee hate blood yeah
see up to maybe four may be old
maybe I don't want to see before I mean
absolutely not
hmm
k boys somewhat hanging wonder what
queen coming to e1 I just goes back
okay i can i can change on the whole
course on the game now with this which
I'm entirely unsure about what the
position otherwise was so bad that I
think I must go for it time morning it
doesn't have b5 because of rooks is six
I think did I getting a queen bee 5c
three then all of a sudden the position
becomes very good for black so why can I
not take there like what r uu k 2 or
something I don't know I take it
mid-back rangas of course week Queen B 5
rugby too and I know it's got all the
miracle moves coming yeah but it does
work hey I should have played be five
somehow at some point and I cannot do it
anymore had bloody hell that's extremely
unlucky because he blundered the black
it wasn't that wasn't the plan tactical
sequence he blundered the porn shoot
yeah probably i never could get you five
and or something cherry five now m but
that's the thing yes to now put the
brakes on some something like that just
okay at 93 is very simple with this one
also okay so yes to play a queen before
and then just a sec i would take is that
yeah I don't know what's going on yeah I
mean okay here i had a very bad position
out of the opening the e3 line is not
easy for black to handle the thing is I
also never studied it so I'm basically
as I said making things up this is very
unusual in the bank owned but I tried
yeah he white accomplished what he
wanted to do is piece on b5 I'm really
just a pawn down here that at least
looked like some counter play wit he's
got everything very nicely coordinate
again this is covering c3 yeah why is
threatening before now is this why I had
to go back this yeah okay now I felt
like I need to do something yeah look II
to a2 was also very strong of course
this is very inhuman this is line and 4b
5 and so on but it was strong yeah I tb5
he blundered this pawn but it doesn't
matter it just worked perfectly because
of my week back rank I have no moves am
both both the hanging and he had this
Ruby to where where the chance this is
made so yeah very nice game by my
opponent gunning getting a very good
position out of the opening and
executing it I think it looked
flawlessly thanks for watching